we can essentially make gasoline we can
take hydrogen we can take CO2 we can do
some fancy chemistry and we can create
gasoline without ever having taken
anything you know out from the ground as
far as fossil fuels the challenge is
it's very expensive and it takes a lot
of energy right so for a racing series
like formula one that's no problem right
they can spend fifty dollars a gallon
and they're not going to cure Porsche
has said recently that they think their
current price per gallon of uh you know
a synthetic fuel that's made using these
processes it's about forty dollars a
gallon and they want to get it done
yeah exactly so it's like we can say
this and if we can get it cheap
um great but you have to think about
theoretical limits like right like
there's a certain amount of energy
required to create that fuel and that
will always be greater than if you were
to just take that energy and put it in a
battery and then move the car